as Benjamin Netanyahu prepares for a
fifth term as Israel's Prime Minister
he's promising to carry out one of the
most controversial acts of his decades
in politics the annexation of illegal
Israeli settlements as well as large
parts of the Jordan Valley totaling
nearly a third of the occupied West Bank
last month he reminded American
evangelical Christians that President
Donald Trump had pledged to endorse it a
couple of months from now I'm confident
that that pledge will be honored that we
will be able to celebrate another
historic moment in the history of
Zionism you call it Netanyahu has made
annexation pledges before often during
election campaigns without following
through some analysts suspect concerns
over regional stability might make him
hold off once again but since the
election annexation talk is strengthened
not diminished Netanyahu has built the
policy into his coalition deal with his
former rival Bennigan's and above all
there's been pre-emptive support from
the Trump administration the US Israeli
annexation mapping team is due to have
finished its work by the end of June the
American ambassador to Israel has said
the u.s. is ready to recognize Israeli
sovereignty within weeks if with
annexation comes a commitment to
negotiate with the Palestinians Nana the
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas says
annexation would see him dissolve all
agreements with the US and Israel
something that could collapse the
Palestinian Authority and leave Israel
with direct responsibility for the
Palestinian people it's a warning he's
made before and not delivered on but
officials say this time is different we
know it is difficult we know that it is
always a matter of survival but we think
that
accepting such as rey de facto is not a
choice you cannot live with such
annexation Netanyahu's prospective Co
Prime Minister Benny Gant's plans to
argue for delay from within government
but he gave up any veto on annexation as
part of the deal that would see him take
the top job in 18 months time the
coalition agreements the United States
and Mike Pompeo is view is quite known
and Donald Trump needs to allow
annexation in order to build up his
evangelical base ahead of a floundering
election campaign so American politics
and Israeli politics are in a unique
place right now to facilitate annexation
European nations are reportedly
considering sanctions there's also the
prospect of Jordan Egypt and other Arab
states pressuring the White House not to
approve but in the end this decision
with all its potential for far-reaching
consequences comes down to two men
Benjamin Netanyahu and Donald Trump